you came back that in the garage with a
big old hips on me he like that this is
the best song this whole car like this
you'll ever see is right you go white
move look so here's the west coast
gospel show finished products in here
from wild to more wild pink mini with
the salwar ski roof as a thousand
swarthy crystals on the roof why so you
can blind an airplane because my wife
got bored this is what she does what
else you got a of a chrome Audi we did
this for a motion of the Tron movie back
in the day so this rap I mean it's a
chrome rap on it so chrome is the
hardest rap to do so this is probably
like a $15,000 rap job opposed to like a
normal $5,000 rap we built these rings
LED rings that go behind the wheel just
dream it I'll build it so this is a
Dodge Charger that was a four-door
that's now a two-door so we cut the car
in half shortened it and made it a
two-door that's how they should have
made the charger they made it a
four-door and I think they messed it up
so we brought the roof down a little bit
as chopped and then that door
we made it longer oh let us see the
process and doing some what is this what
is this this is crazy
well I am is a good client friend of
mine that has these futuristic ideas all
the time so we sit to draw on some stuff
and we came up with this this definitely
looks like we'll earn it it started as a
design of on a piece of paper we came up
with it we built the whole body from
scratch we built the drivetrain it's got
a Corvette drivetrain in it so it's
motor you know ls3 in it so y'all came
up with futuristic ideas and they're
gonna design them to start shaping the
metal start building it and then
obviously the interior you know had to
be futuristic as well so everything's
ran off the iPad the a/c controls the
door poppers like everything's run off
that
a car company came and said they wanted
to buy this pet and what would you
charge that would be a tough negotiation
I think it's in the millions for sure
this is one of those cars you know like
you could pull up in this and you could
pull up in the dopest Lambo that's out
there and they're gonna look at this
first what was something like this cause
this is Cosmo done in a year me yeah
just pay you a little hundred write it
down look holiday yeah followed it in a
briefcase that's what I wanted but you
know it never works like that right now
I don't know what this is
so it started life as a DeLorean that's
what it was born May yes but we took it
to 2020 we widen the whole car eight
inches so like from here to here we had
you don't think the things it's not the
one big bright light as you can see from
the camera actually huge is brake light
I've ever seen in the DeLorean obviously
really when they got the cars they
didn't really have a motor so they
headed no the motor was like like a
go-kart motor so we had to pull that out
and put a Corvette motor because in
supercharged so you get to the future
this car actually runs yeah it moves and
it's all that we built it all out of
aluminum so it's superlight these cars
were all stainless so building it out of
aluminum dropped a whole lot of weight
off of it we added a bigger motor in it
which gave it some power and then the
interiors good wow that's fast this is
the - we did the wood floor all right
with a little bit of stainless steel
trim just to give it a little touch oh
how much does this remake of the
DeLorean I'm five hundred half a meal
yes or half a ticket half a ticket you
got the beats speaker in here yes sir
this is so nice and this thing I can't
really take you
right I feel like you're already going
somewhere I really really like and
appreciate the mind that you have and
then it's just like being able to get
these images out that's the thing is
like I get them in my head and now I got
a really good team upstairs where we
could put them on paper and then my team
out in the back can build it you know
it's like bringing dreams to reality I
mean this is definitely a dream come
true right here now you know me I've
been watching West Coast Customs since
they had exhibit on that [ __ ]
pimping rides so it was cool to finally
meet Ryan in person you know when you
see people on TV and stuff like that
kind of like me you see me an airport a
lot of futuristic ideas the DeLorean the
will.i.am car a lot of special things
going on the price range I can see me
[ __ ] on my checkbook too so I'm gonna
have to be down with that I'm [ __ ]
with Ryan heater [ __ ] double salute to
you and what you have going on my man
true